BENGHAZI.
>> Tucker: THANKS.
TRACE GALLAGHER, APPRECIATE
THAT.
IT'S BEEN ONLY A LITTLE OVER 24
HOURS SINCE THE MAJOR DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL WAS RELEASE.
WHAT IS THE PRESS MISSING.
KIM IS ON THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL BOARD.
WHAT JUMPED OUT WHEN YOU READ
THIS?
>> MOST OF THE HEADLINES TODAY
HAVE BEEN FOCUSSED ON JIM COMEY.
NO QUESTION THAT THIS WAS A VERY
DAMNING INDICTMENT OF HIS
LEADERSHIP WHILE HE WAS THERE.
THEN, AGAIN, DEMOCRATS AND A LOT
IN THE MEDIA WOULD LIKE TO PIN
IT ALL ON HIM.
WHAT STRUCK HIM THIS WAS A
SEARING INDICTMENT OF THE ENTIRE
FBI AND ITS CULTURE.
THE ARGUMENT THEY LIVE BY A RULE
THEY THEMSELVES CRAFT AND IMPOSE
RULES ON EVERYBODY ELSE, BUT
THEY DON'T LIVE BY THEM.
WE HAVE EXAMPLES IN HERE OF
EMPLOYEES USING THEIR HOME
COMPUTERS AND CELLPHONES FOR
WORK BUSINESS.
WE FOUND OUT THAT COMEY'S ENTIRE
STAFF WAS COMPLICIT IN HELPING
HIM CONCEAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICES THE PRESS CONFERENCE
IS HILLARY CLINTON.
WE HAVE UNAUTHORIZED CONTACTS
WITH THE PRESS.
AN ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL
TIPPING OFF THE HILLARY CLINTON
TEAM.
HE DIDN'T ABIDE BY A RECUSAL.
ANDREW McCABE LEAKING AND LYING
ABOUT IT TO THE FBI AGENTS WHO
QUESTIONED HIM.
THIS IS A WIDESPREAD PROBLEM.
AT LEAST IN THE LEADER SHOULD BE
ACROSS THE FBI.